property development is just something
that right now i'm spending most of my
energy
on because here's the thing boris
johnson the pro
the prime minister saying build build
build permitted development
they're loosening up on planning it's
very very profitable right now and i
think as a property investor what you
need to do
is you need to see where the wind's
blowing and then set yourself for that
so i'm doing a lot of property
development stuff i'm excited
i want to i'm going to be viewing
different sites all across the country
right now
i'm currently in the midlands uh i've
been i've just been in buckinghamshire
i'm heading down tomorrow to the north
west of the country
and i want to i want to just vlog it
show you guys around introduce you to
some people
so let's see what happens
i'm with ben ben's the director of our
property development company ben what
are the top three
tips in property development make sure
you do due diligence
yup get a structural engineer structural
engineer survey
yep and also a ground investigation wow
talking to structural engineers yeah we
actually have one with us right now
so this is our structural engineer his
name is david all right david i'm asking
the same question
when buying a development project what
are the top three
things that you look for getting a
survey done like
ben said uh making sure that the the
development
is financially viable as in you can do
everything you want to do it
yeah and uh getting getting the planning
permission sorted out straightaway
yep interesting okay and this is anthony
now anthony is completing on friday on
friday
on a pub a pub are you going to be
converting it into
so we turn it into six apartments nice
talk to us about that so uh we we
purchased this pub last year pre-corona
virus and we're gonna convert it into
six apartments do a two-story extension
on the back of it
so we've had full planning to go through
on this now and it's gonna be a great
rental area we have some great rental
properties
as a result of it so we're really
excited looking forward to getting it
going and this dude as well he literally
um started from with nothing nothing
started with absolutely nothing and has
built up his property portfolio
now i call this guy for advice like if
i'm doing deals and stuff even right now
picking his brain david ben
my advice would be get around good
people get around people that are
successful get around winners get around
people that want you to win
because i believe that you are a resort
of the people that you spend the most
time with
if you want to see anthony's pub if you
want to see it
comment below let us know you want to
see the pub conversion would you be
doing a tour oh definitely yeah you'll
be up for me coming around yeah we'll
get get some video
footage of it if only we had a
videographer oh would you look at that
this is anthony's face when he very
first saw my castle
you like that man oh that's amazing that
that's what it's all about
i'm gonna do a whole new video about
this an update on the castle by the way
if you want to see that comment below
that's going to be coming soon big
building slow
but big that by the way this guy as well
he just said something interesting which
i thought had to repeat he says he will
not buy a property
if he has to leave as little as five
grand into the deal is that right
correct yeah what did you say what did
you say what were you worth
there's no point in uh you know putting
doing a uh buy to let or
hmo or anything else unless you if
you're not going to pull all your money
back out or at least leave five grand in
yeah go to the next property so if
you're gonna have to just leave six
grand in you you're not interested
no that's basically three houses that's
what he wants three houses
is the castle gonna be a free castle you
have to wait and see in the next
update video by the way watch this space
because liv cook is going to be the next
big thing in property
seriously that's big she set up a couple
of uh property company last year
and you've already got how many houses
three investments
three investments and now looking to do
something a little bit bigger
development
development baby look at something
really juicy
and i hope that we're going to get a
really good documentary out of it i'm
sure we will i'm sure it's going to burn
because you know what there's not enough
education out there around development
you said this you've read so many books
on property investment yeah i've read
like tons and tons of books watched all
the youtube videos on property real
estate in the uk
but never came across anything in depth
or even even brief
about development so hopefully we can
change that a little bit
and absolutely and i'm really glad to be
working with liv because i know she's
going to be ridiculously
successful why did you choose me as your
mentor when it comes to development
who better that's the question i'm one
that goes i'm a winner come on
i look for the best and i think you were
the best so i reached out and
why did you accept me i accepted you
because because i'm so enamored with
your football tricks
and no i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
although there are amazing you know
because you got massive drive
and i thought you're going to be
successful anyway if i can be part of
that story
then they'll make a good team absolutely
i'm excited
so watch this space folks liv cook uh
check out her property channel she's got
a massive following on social media for
a football tricks which is incredible
but she's also got a property
uh a property instagram which is it's
new it's in infancies uh live cook
properties
when you've got look i've got so many
good people around me i've got
structural engineers
architects planning advisors builders
uh developers all kinds of amazingly
knowledgeable property people around me
if you want to hear from a particular
type of person what kind of content do
you want who do you want to hear from
what do you want to see see all the time
every day i'm out viewing different
sites and projects pieces of land
developments
refurbs what do you want to see comment
below
i'm out on the road coronavirus is
finishing
we hope we're allowed to leave the house
now so i'm excited to be able to just
travel around
make some more content comment below let
me know what you want to see because
i've got some ridiculously exciting
stuff
over the coming weeks and months comment
below subscribe smash the like button
i'll see you tomorrow